all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts where
I give my thoughts while I do my makeup
my hair
um or just you know whatever I'm doing
in the morning before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that way
you're gonna be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in
let's get started guys
do you see this I got burnt so bad
people act like gingers don't have
problems we have problems okay they
always say we don't have a soul but the
biggest problem is do you see how pale I
am do you see the
so
I was thinking about
the problems that women will talk about
in their relationships
and I was thinking and this was kind of
like
a red a concept got to be red pills on
if women are arguing with their husbands
that is the fault of the woman well it's
both of their faults
but the question is why are you arguing
with your husband now this might sound
crazy to those of you
getting red pill but if you if you've
heard your parents argue before or your
friends or maybe you've argued
it's the woman's fault now it's the
man's fault for putting up with it and
not establishing say like boundaries in
a relationship that sort of thing but
when you think about it
if you have a boss that's arguing with
an employee
the problem is the employee like they're
not supposed to argue with the boss
they're supposed to follow orders even
if they disagree
and that's the problem with women today
is even conservative women don't push
this even conservative women will still
say that I that you should have an equal
say and what is scary is that they're
even the marriages that stay together
it's very much the man is just trying to
avoid an argument and an avoid a fight
with the woman and it's very much the
man is just he doesn't want an argument
so he does whatever the wife wants and
then we as women will say well why don't
you just choose conservative women
and in hindsight I look at a lot of the
Christian conservative women and they
really confuse me
because a lot of them
and I'd like to say I am
pro-christianity I'm pro-everything I
believe in all that stuff but I just
noticed some interesting like trends
like I saw this um woman on a podcast
talking to Justin Waller about how you
know he needs more discipline in his
life and he should just pick one woman
but I've never heard that equal energy
for the women that don't pick one man
you know like she's he's saying I'm open
with this this is the lifestyle I pick
and
she's out there well why why don't you
just she like why don't you just pick
one woman you have all this discipline
well I've never heard that same
conversation with the non-virgin women
that are on every podcast now
has a non-virgin myself
you know but the difference is I'm not
we're trying not to act like we're
better than anybody
but the Christian women confuse me
because a lot of them
will come in and say they want
to live on a farm right and they want to
like live on a farm in the middle of
nowhere but I'm like you live in the
city
I just get confused and they'll be like
I want a masculine man to chop wood or
whatever and I'm just like
you don't
even eat like Farmers like do you guys
know what a farmer's wife would entail
sorry that's a little off topic
um
but I've just noticed like
a bit of double standards when it comes
to that stuff where we're always shaming
the men for following their mating
strategy like if I said to the
Christians is it wrong for a woman to
want to get the best guy she get could
get
um so whether that's money looks or
maybe in the Christian it's like a
closest relationship to God carrot
Charisma kind whatever it is is that
wrong
they would say no I would imagine
but for some reason it's wrong for the
men to get as many women as they can get
now I do understand like the Bible like
I'm Catholic you know we believe one man
one woman for Life get married
but the difference is the women aren't
virgins today
so it's like we're holding women to a
lower only five percent of women are
virgins on their wedding night so we're
holding women to a lower standard than
ever before and expecting men to have a
higher standard than ever before and
when the men are saying you know
I'm just not gonna buy these products
you know I think I'll just rent them
short term can you really blame them
and the issue is a lot of Christian
women will still use the same language
that the feminists use when they're
speaking about their husbands they'll
say an equal partnership like I'll hear
Christian women talk about an equal
partnership me men and women are equal
we are certainly not equal
men kill us in everything
they're better than us and literally
every metric like if you look at the top
chefs the men are the best chefs they
beat us at our own games
raising children the memories better
children it's like
we're not equal we're actually men are
superior and once you understand this
concept you'll see how odd relationships
are today but it's not until you like
understand like you're red pilled to the
point you can you can say Okay men are
better than women women should not have
an equal say in decisions
and arguing really is the woman's fault
because think about if you work for
somebody
you don't argue argue them when they
give you an order you might quit if you
think your boss is a dick but you don't
argue with them but for some reason in
marriage women think it's okay to argue
with their husbands and you just see the
husband becoming a shell of himself
sad really
you should as a woman
if my husband answered honestly would he
say I'm a good wife
if if my husband
knew that I wouldn't see the answer
would he say I'm a good wife and I think
even in the church I think a lot of the
men would say no
um there's this one couple I knew in a
church and she didn't want children
and you could tell he did and that woman
was on birth control for like 10 plus
years that's not godly
um and I think that's
the complaints that the men are coming
from like even if the women are more
um submissive and more pure in the
church like
they still don't really have traditional
relationships because a lot of times
you'll have men in the church saying
things like my wife runs the household
your wife isn't supposed to run the
household like it's very and even if
you're not super religious or you don't
understand it completely the language
you start to pick up on this stuff like
it's funny because
I didn't know any of this red pill stuff
but I always picked up on like the simpy
guys that would just
telling women what they want to hear
like people can sense kind of [__]
when they hear it
um
and I think that's a problem in 2023
where even in the relationships that are
better right
even in the relationships that are more
traditional a lot of times the wife
still runs the house
and we shouldn't strive for that or want
that but you know call me crazy I don't
know
call me crazy
um
oh I'm home and I feel like I'm a
happier person at home I just love being
home
um
I'm home I'm going
on one more podcast before I leave the
UK
um I'm going to London on I think like
around the 10th I think one of my sister
to Greece for a couple days so I might I
don't know we'll see we'll see but
um yeah I'm going to London
and I'm moving back here in the fall for
everyone that wants to apply to our
Chicago office we're probably not gonna
hire in Chicago until the fall
so I mean like we can have conversation
I get so many messages and a lot of the
talents actually seem really good but I
just can't like do anything with it
until fall so you know keep